in the last video we went over the
multiplication tables for 1 through 9
and I ran at a time and it actually was
a good thing because 1 through 9 are
kind of the core multiplication tables
and you'll see that if you know all your
multiplication tables from 1 to 9 so you
know any number between 1 and 9 times
any other number between 1 and 9 you can
actually do any multiplication problem
out there but what I want to do now is I
want to complete the multiplication
tables for 10 11 and 12 so what is 10
times let's just start at 0 10 times 0
anything times 0 is 0 10 zeros are 0 0
plus 0 plus 0 10 times is still 0 what's
10 times 1 10 times 1 well that's just
10 one time or one plus itself 10 times
that's 10 I think this is second nature
to you at this point what's 10 times 2
10 times 2 meant to switch colors but I
didn't 10 times 2 that's 10 plus 10
which is 20 fair enough and notice we
went up by 10 the first time we went up
by 10 again to get to 20 what's 10 times
3 well that's 10 plus 10 plus 10 or we
could view it as 10 times 2 plus another
10 which is equal to 30 what's 10 times
4 I think you start to see a pattern a
10 times 4 is equal to 40
notice 10 times 4 is equal to 40 if I
were to tell you what is 10 times let me
do another color 5 well that's equal to
50 50 10 times anything 10 times
anything is that anything with a zero
behind it so the 10 times tables you
almost won't have to remember it so
let's just let's just keep going what's
10 times 6 it's equal to 66 zero what's
10 times 7
seventy ten times a this is almost
ridiculous ten times eight is eighty ten
times nine ninety ten times ten now this
is interesting
ten times ten so it'll be a ten
let's see me write this ten times let me
do it in a in this orange color ten
times ten so it'll be ten tens or ten
with a zero behind it
there you go notice everything I'm just
whatever times ten I just add a zero and
I get the next number so it's a hundred
and I think you understand why that is I
had a ten to itself 10 times that each
10 you know you go from 10 20 30 30 is
just three tens or ten times three 90 is
just nine tens or nine times ten let's
keep going so 10 times 11 is equal to 11
with the zero behind it 110 finally 10
times 12 10 times 12 is equal to 120 now
just just for fun these are your kind of
your 10 times tables but now that you
know the pattern you can do anything if
I asked you what 5732 times 10 is times
10 what's it going to be it's going to
be this number with just one more zero
so it's going to be I won't read it out
get at five seven three two with the
zero behind it and just so you know this
little comma that I wrote it in the
number there let's just make it easier
for me to read that number so and you
put the comma you start over here and
every third number you put the comma so
here I'm going to put the comma right
there so now I can read this because it
calm the comma doesn't really add or to
take anything away from the number just
helps me read it now 5732 times ten is
fifty seven thousand three hundred and
twenty I just had to add a zero there
but that was a pretty straightforward
multiplication and those we had five
thousand times ten and we got 250
something thousand when we multiply them
so that's similar to five times 10 is
equal to 50 but instead of five I had a
and so I got a 50,000 in something and
there's all this other stuff we're going
to learn more about how to do problems
like this in the future
but I thought I would introduce you to
the idea that just from this little
pattern of adding a 0 you already know
your tens times tables now let's do our
11s our 11 so 11 is get a little bit
well they start off easy then they get a
little a little more difficult as we get
into high numbers so 11 times 0 this is
easy this is 0 11 times 1 this is also
easy it's 11 11 times 2 we're going to
start seeing a pattern here it's 11 plus
11 or we could add 2 to itself 11 times
but that is equal to 22 if we do 11
times 3 it is equal to 33 11 times 4 is
equal to 44 I think this is becoming
obvious to you what's 11 times 5 11
times 5 is 55 I just put the 5 twice
what's 11 times 6 it's 66 11 times 7 is
84 not kidding I didn't want to mess
with you like that but no of course it's
77 77 you just repeat the number twice
77 let me switch colors 11 times 8 is
equal to 88 11 times 9 is equal to 99
now what's 11 times 12 11 times 12
you might I'm sorry I skipped 10 11
times 10 you might want to say it's 10
to 10 no that's wrong it's not 10 to 10
like 19 it's not 10 to 10 so that little
pattern that we had where you just
repeat the number that only worked for
one digit number so it only works for
one through nine 11 times 10 well we
could think about it a couple of ways we
can add 11 to 99 so we could say it's 99
plus 11 and what's that that's equal to
110 and I'm going to show you how to do
well hopefully you've already watched
the video on how to add two-digit
numbers like this but that's 110 or you
could just use the property from the
tens times tables that we learned where
if you just take 11 times 10 you add a
zero to the 11 you get 100 and
ehn right that's the 11 right there
finally let's do 11 times 12 11 times 12
no easy way to remember this you just
kind of should remember it or you can
say look it's going to be 11 more than
11 times sorry I keep skipping things we
should do 11 times 11 first let me make
sure this is clear we're doing 11 times
11 before we go to 11 times 12 so 11
times 11 it's going to be 11 more then
11 times 10 right so we add 11 to this
11 plus 110 is 121 121 and actually as
you'll see there actually is an order as
we get to higher multiples of 11 but
I'll leave that to a future video and
then finally we're at 11 times 12 11
times 12 and we could add 11 to itself
12 times we could add 12 to itself 11
times or we could just say hey this is
going to be 11 more 11 more then 11
times 11 so that is what you add 11 to
this and what you get you get 132 132 I
just added 121 plus 11 and then got 132
now the other way you could have said is
what's 10 times 12 10 times 12 we
already knew that that was 120 so 11
times 12 because we're multiplying 12 by
one more should be 12 more than that so
that should be 132 so two ways to get
the exact same answer all right now
let's do our 12 times tables 12 times
tables and it's once you know this you
are ready to tackle any type of
multiplication problem we'll do that in
future videos so 12 times 0 super-easy 0
12 times 1 also super easy is 12 now it
gets interesting we're going to
increment increase by 12 every time 12
times 2 is equal to 24 12 plus 12 is 24
right 12 times not 22
let me rewrite that 12 times 3 is going
to be 12 plus 12 plus 12 or we
right that is 12 times 2 why not you see
my brain is doing the wrong things we
could rewrite that as 12 times 2 plus 12
or we could rewrite that as 24 plus 12
either way all of these get us to 36 and
that's notice that's just that plus 12
12 times 4 12 times 4 is equal to 48 and
you wait there's a lot of ways you could
think about you could say 11 times 4 is
44 right 11 times 4 is equal to 44 and
you could say that's you go up by one
more four so you get to 12 times four or
you could say 12 times 3 is 36 and you
can add 112 to it to get to 48 either
way works and that's because we can
multiply in either direction let's keep
going 12 times 5 is equal to 60 all
right 10 times 5 is 50 11 times 5 is 55
so 12 times 5 is 60 12 times 6 is equal
to what it's going to be 12 more than
this it's going to equal 72 12 times 7
12 more than this again 12 more than 72
is 84 and I'm serious you know I'm
probably a lot older than you are and
still because I might have I still in my
head to confirm I go to some 12 times
tables that I remember is definitely
right like Oh 12 times 5 and sometimes
in my head I say oh let me add another
12 oh yeah definitely my memory was
correct correct 12 times 6 is 72 all
right then you go to 12 times 8 at 12 to
the 12 times 7 96
12 times 9 12 times 9
well you had 12 to this so it's 108 108
and then 12 times 10 this is an easy one
right we just add a 0 to the 12 you get
120 or we could add 12 to 108 either way
12 times 11 12 times 11 we just did this
add 12 to this you get to 132 and then
12 times 12
is equal to 144 this actually shows up
if I had a dozen of dozen eggs a dozen
is 12 or if I had eight I think a gross
is actually 12 dozen so that's 144 eggs
so you'll actually end up seeing this
number a lot more than you would expect
in life but anyway we've now completed
all of our all of our multiplication
tables and I really encourage you to
take the time now to go and memorize
them make some flashcards use its use
the the little software thing that I
wrote on my website you could try that
out as as of September 2009 it's it's
working I haven't touched it in a while
but I'm going to I'm actually probably
going to rebuild it soon so if you're
watching this video in the Year 2200
well I would have probably not exist
anymore but hopefully you'll get a
better version of the software app but
you should practice it you should get
your parents to quiz you you should get
quiz note cards you should just be
mumbling to yourself as you walk to
school what is 12 times 9 what is 11
times 11 and you should quiz each other
because it'll pay huge rewards to you
later on in life see in the next video